it's not necessarily about uh being
competitive or not being competitive
it's about knowing the game that you're
in when you're in it so for example if
you're up for a job and somebody else is
up for a job that is finite there's a
beginning middle and end and there will
be a winner and there will be a loser
and you should have a finite mindset in
in that scenario of course you play to
win however everybody knows that you
have to have a little bit of an infinite
mindset in the back of your mind for
example a a gate agent in an airline we
want them to have a finite mindset we
want that plane to leave on time
beginning middle and end done reset but
we want them to have an infinite mindset
we want them to treat us nicely because
they want us to come back again it's not
just one and done we want to we want to
we want to treat our clients with
respect it's not just about doing a good
job and getting out of there there is
actually good customer service so that
we get hired again or recommended in
other words we have a sense that there's
more Beyond right now but it's more
about when you think about the business
at a writ large right the there is
competition in infinite game the the
truest competitor in infant game is
yourself
right to say I'm the best EX you know in
in the industry is nonsense because you
don't know everybody else and some
people are better at some things and
some people are better at others it's
actually a stupid comparison it's a
stupid thing to say it's it's it's
empirically not true
um but you can strive to be a better
version of yourself
how do I do better this year than I did
last year how do I improve my service
this year make it better than it was
last year how to make my leadership
better this year than it was last year
how do I improve my tech this year than
it was last year whatever the thing is
there's always a constant and intense
drive to win and or to improve rather
but when we say to be to win uh there is
no such thing as a Finish Line even
annual goals are arbitrary like how do
we come up with our annual goals here's
how we do it we sit down we go so uh how
much business you want to do next year
how about this number
how about this number okay and that's it
that's how you picked your annual goal
and the reason we choose annual is
because that's when we pay taxes why not
why not 17 months that seems perfectly
legitimate it's all arbitrary and so we
become fixated about hitting an
arbitrary number on an arbitrary date we
are so upset if we miss it and we think
we've won something when we hit it it's
nonsense we have to change our mindset
away from thinking like a sporting event
and think of it more like lifestyle
right running a business is much more
like trying to be healthy right so for
example what are all the things you have
to do to be healthy well you got to eat
right you got to exercise you got to
nurse your personal relationships you
got to get enough sleep there's probably
15 other things it's very hard to do all
those things well all the time what does
it take to build a great business you
need great sales you need great
marketing you need great leadership you
need great people you actually got to do
the service it's very hard to do all
those things well all the time but it's
a striving it's a striving right and you
can absolutely have arbitrary goals
right I want to lose x amount of weight
by X date okay great and you weigh
yourself every day some days you feel
good about yourself some days you feel
bad about yourself we love metrics
there's nothing wrong with metrics you
can't run a marathon without mile
markers it's actually unnerving metrics
help us feel like we're making progress
it makes feel like the work is actually
uh building something
and it help us measure it helps us
measure speed and distance that's what
metrics do speed and how far has our
business gotten how fast are we growing
that's good right and let's say you hit
your goal you you lose that amount of
weight on the right date
you feel great you celebrate
and then you still have to keep
exercising for the rest of your life
like you haven't won anything yeah right
but what's I think more interesting is
what happens if you don't lose the
weight by that by that date what happens
if you miss the goal yeah you know what
happens
nothing
happens in fact you're way healthier now
than you were when you started because
you've been doing all the right things
to be healthy you just picked the wrong
time and the wrong date uh the wrong uh
the wrong number on the wrong date and
you can clearly look at the trend that
you'll hit it in a month or two no big
deal right and so business is the same
way which is what's more important in an
infinite game is to see the trend data
so we we do this all the time we bonus
people because they hit a goal and we
ignore people because we ignore the
trend right but we don't know how they
hit the goal or if it's going to be able
to continue what's way more important is
the trend data because it means you're
building a healthy business you just
pick the wrong date on the wrong time
that's an infinite mindset